Alright, so let's
take a look at
what this looks
like in R. So if
we open up our
lab 3 R project,
we can see an example
of what this would
potentially look
like if it was coded
in R. And just like
the lab 2, this is
just shown as an
example to show, okay,
that same sort
of analysis,
what does that
code look like?
There's no expectation
here yet that
you'd be writing
this manually,
but if you wanted
to try it in R,
there's some examples
here to get you started.
Also, any coding agent,
ChatGPT, Copilot,
Claude, is going
to do a pretty good
job at getting you
started on that code
as well. I want a
chart, a bar chart
that shows these
categories, this metric.
Help me put
that together.
is uh is a good way
to get a feel for
what this looks like
so we'll work in
lab 3 our companion
here uh the q md
the q quarto markdown
file uh we'll open
that up um and then
if we hit render
uh right away we
should be able to see
what that output looks
like and this one is
a little bit different
it renders to an
HTML web page instead
of a PDF you could
render this as a PDF
if you wanted but these
are I think these
show up a little bit
better in in a browser
so it'll take a
couple seconds here
and you can kind of run
through and see what's
happening here so
you know this stuff
was already done you
know obviously if
you're opening up the
file it's in there I've
already gone through
it and loaded that
setup information, so
you should be all be
ready to go there.
And then this walks
through what code it
ran. So it loaded
the libraries that it
needed for this.
So ggplot2 is the
library that most
examples that you'll see,
it's kind of a go-to
for visualizing data
in R. And then some
of the other libraries
that we've loaded
before, dplyr and tidy
are, you those things
that make those
data pipelines work
are in there as well.
It does a little
bit of setup
work here to set a theme.
You know I asked it
to do a theme similar
to Tableau, but
there's all sorts of
different examples
out there of different
kind of looks and
feels that are
that are pretty easy
to implement here.
And then this is
also loading a color
palette similar to what
tableau uses by default
and again all these
options can be can
be changed if needed
so first one here is
going to do some data
setup so it's going
to read in our our
sample file that we used
in in tableau and that
we used in an excel
and it's going to
create a couple of
data points that it
needs for the chart so
you know here you can
see it is creating a
month variable that
doesn't exist in here
a little bit more
work to get this going
in in R than it was in
tableau tableau sees
that date automatically
builds in you know
your year your month
all that sort of
stuff in R you have to
usually specifically
call those out but
as you can see here
there's some built
-in functions that are
able to do that. We
don't have to go in
and manually try to
figure out, okay,
what was September,
what was October,
whatever. There's a
month function that can
get at that same with
our quarter function,
just to duplicate
the views and
things that we're seeing
in Tableau. And we
can see that we have
12,000 rows here,
12,000 crash IDs,
you know, same sort
of thing that we saw
in Tableau, because
it's the exact same
file that's feeding
this. So first one here,
skip past the code and
go to the output, you
know, so you can see,
okay, this is the
same sort of chart that
we built in Tableau,
same sort of thing
that we built in Excel.
And here's the code
that's doing that.
So kind of two parts
here. First part is
going to be building
the actual data.
It's going to feed
the chart. And when
you see examples
or when you ask
an agent to do this,
It's usually going
to follow a similar
practice, which
makes sense if you
think about it.
The only stuff
that's showing
up in the chart
is like the
summary that we're
trying to show.
So it makes sense to
kind of split that
out to say, okay,
this is how we're
creating the summary.
You know, same sort
of thing that we
would see in a pivot
table or a tabular
view of that data.
you know, this is
basically building
the data that would
feed that table
and then on top
of that we're
layering to say, okay,
instead of showing
that as a table,
I want you to
show this as a
plot, as a bar plot
you know, bar
chart, you know,
here's how to set that up
so if we run through
here we can see what's
happening, so we see
our data pipes here
you know, saying,
okay, remember, okay,
that pipe is saying,
okay, whatever
happens in this line,
take the result and
do you know, further
action. It keeps
flowing down that
pipe from one segment
to the other. So take
our crashes data,
filter that to say okay,
you know, if there's
any missing primary
cause, get rid of
that. So this is NA
function is checking
to see, okay, was
there null data
there, missing data
there? And then this
exclamation point
negates that to
say, okay, the
opposite of that.
So basically saying,
okay, anywhere
where there is data.
Primary cause in,
you know, selecting
from this list,
unable to determine,
not applicable.
It is giving us a
count of primary cause
and giving it the
name crash count.
And then this slice
max function is saying,
okay, give me the top
10 and don't bring
in any ties. So basically
the first 10 that
it sees. Next one here
then is where that
ggplot2 library kicks in
is we are making
this plot.
So these are always going
to go in the same order.
So it starts with our
data. So take that
ranking data that
we just built, you
know, all this,
built this, and then
we assigned it to
that variable ranking,
which is basically
the data that would
fill that table. So
saying take that.
This AES stands for
like aesthetics,
you know, just say
okay, this is the, this
is what we're going
to show, basically.
What's your X variable?
What's your Y, um,
or not variable,
but what's your X
dimension? What's
your Y dimension? So
in X, we're going
to have crash count,
you know, our, our
measure here, um,
you know, that we
created up above.
And then here we're
going to have,
um,
our primary contributory
cause, and then
it's going to reorder
it by crash count to say
okay you know sort
it in in descending
order is going to make
us our basic plot but
if you just ran this
it would run without an
error but it's not
going to show anything
nothing's going to show
up in your plot it's
basically going to
set that canvas when
these plus signs here
are then adding different
layers onto that so
how do we want to
visualize that we're
going to add geometry and
this is a column you
know there's geom line
geom point there's
all sorts of different
options there but it's
saying okay how do
you want to show this
with a column what's
and then we can set our
options there to say
okay fill it with
tableau colors one which
is blue we change this
to two it would change
to a different color
on to that so that's
going to give us our
bar chart onto that
add a scale for y you
know with our labels
add a scale for x with
our um you know our
um our count and then
add a title onto that
you know with our you
know whatever we want
to say there and
then last one here is
and that then it gets
assigned to this ranking
plot and then that's
what it gets printed
out so a little bit
more complex than
what we've been dealing
with before but if
you kind of follow
line by line and think
through okay how would
I how would I build
this in in tableau or
build this in in excel
you can kind of see
where some of those
different elements
are coming in you know
if any of these were
confusing or you
know okay how to scale
why discrete work
you know you can look
them up any agent
is going to be able
to kind of parse
that out and give
you a description
okay here's how here's
how that comes into
into play here uh
nominal comparison
you know shown here
you know it's going to
be a very similar
process what's our data
you know what's that
plot look like um you
know and then this
is showing okay it
doesn't have that hover
over you know functionality
that the tableau
does where it's going
to show the actual
value so it's building
you know this table
here to show okay
here's what here's
what's included with uh
with those different
things uh time series
you know does a different
approach here instead
of doing each line
differently it does
a concept called small
multiples where we're
taking okay all of
our different um our
different um categories
of weather here it
puts it on you know
the same size graph
and just does a lot of
them together so it's
easy to kind of scan
through and see okay
which one which one
is different which one
is trending up which
one is trending down
uh part to whole you
know it shows some
calculations there to
you know figure out what
does that um what
does that calculation
look like to get those
categories um and then
you know from there
shows okay how to how
to specifically call
out okay here's here's
why I want these
different things colored
so it's it's showing
you know a couple
different options of
how to you know how to
do this how to you know
hide that data like
we did in tableau um
you know how to do
bins how to do box
plots you know some of
these are a little
bit easier than others
because some of these
are just built-in chart
types in ggplot too
um so you can kind of
run through those you
know for mapping you
know you can't do
anything too wild here
unless you pull in like
an external mapping
service like google
maps or something like
that to get or open
maps to get street view
or, um,
you know, streets and
points of interest,
things like that. Um,
but it is using, you
know, because we have
that, um, latitude,
longitude, you know,
it's kind of plotting out
what that looks like.
And we can kind of
see what the, you know,
that pattern makes
sense that, okay, these
are, these are your
roads feeding into,
uh, into downtown sort
of thing. You can plot,
you know, right on
those, where, where are
those accidents, um,
occurring.
Uh, so like I said,
that's, you know just
meant as an example to
show you know kind of
what's possible in
tableau and you get much
more complex you know
charts in this so you
know look through examples
if you want to play
around with this you
could um you know any
coding agent is going
to be able to hop in
there and help you out
with that as well um
you can kind of play
with these as well you
know as with anything
you can in that markdown
file itself you can
run that code uh kind
of line by line here
just remember that if you
try to run something
here and these lines
haven't been loaded we
don't have data loaded
yet it's going to
fail you can run these
you have to go and run
you know each of these
kind of individually
to get that data loaded
or you can click that
you know this button
here run all chunks
above we'll load that in
and then when you
run that it should uh
should come out here and
then you can start to
start to play around
with that so this is
provided as example you
know this isn't going
to be you know something
that is going to
be a main focus of the
class but I did want
to you know kind of
give you a feel for okay
what are the what are
the libraries that come
into play what's kind
of the process that
comes into play if
we're running this in um
an arm.